one piece might actually be the best
live action adaptation ever but there
are a ton of changes that were actually
made from the original story like how
instead of meeting Zorro tied up at the
Marine base he is literally introduced
by chopping this dude in half stuffing
him into a bag and taking him straight
into a bar like seriously what the heck
is going on here and actually speaking
of bars they also added neon lights to
many of the bars in the series like what
then I guess the whole One Piece world
has upgraded from the anime because
electricity seems to be just a normal
thing pretty much everywhere here I mean
it even shows up on battleships and even
in Kaya's Mansion okay but now let's go
back to the very beginning for probably
the biggest change in the entire live
action that's because vice admiral GARP
shows up at Roger's execution and gives
this super serious speech which is not
like his character from the original
show at all but that was just a start
because garp's entire storyline of
chasing down Luffy was just completely
made up for the live action specifically
although yes he did originally train
Kobe and hamappo also in the manga the
anime and while I really enjoyed the
added development for Kobe the extra
attention of the Marine thread and some
mind-blowingly hilarious helmeto scenes
that we'll talk about in just a moment
the overall Vibe of GARP just barely
resembles the Loose Cannon rule breaking
vice admiral that we all know from the
anime and as speaking of the legendary
helmeppo himself he was pretty much just
a Goofy character from the anime but he
had the most shocking scene in the
entire live action series when in the
very first episode he was just caught
butt naked playing with Zorro swords
looking like he needs to compensate for
something and what's even more
impressive though is the absolute
Powerhouse of a battleship that GARP now
rides around on I mean honestly this is
much much more intimidating than his
original ship in the anime right here
notice kind of cute on the other hand
one of the most disappointing changes
from me was that the live action just
completely skipped the very end of
Luffy's backstory because in case you
don't know in the anime this scene shows
Luffy at age 17 then ready to set out to
see on his adventure and as he leaves he
lands this massive punch that completely
knocks out this giant sea monster
showing us all just how much Luffy has
actually grown but nope just completely
cut from this version but maybe they
skipped it for this insane reason
because there is no doubt in my mind
that the live-action versions of the
characters are way weaker overall than
in the original story yeah I said it I
mean they were literally trapped by
buggy inside a simple wooden box but
Zorro and Luffy were so weak that they
couldn't even break out of that although
later on in the live action we actually
see Luffy apparently punching through
Stone so a little bit of a head
scratcher here for me but actually one
other awesome change is that nami's
first staff can now collapse into a size
that can be easily carried on her waist
which is pretty cool if you ask me she
didn't have that in the manga I'm
actually speaking of Nami we see her
actually doing burglar stuff in the live
action like breaking into a safe which
sadly we never actually got to see much
during the anime or Manga Plus I was
completely shocked when Nami saw the
devastating damage that buggy did to
Orange town I mean damn this had way way
more impact than in the original story
but of course that's not the only change
to Buggy's part of the story because in
the live action the clown is like 10
times more evil than in the actual anime
I mean originally he never kidnapped all
the villagers or threatened to torture a
little kid like and the live action
actually gave us a very very rare big
trap Bobby body parts in the crates here
because if we actually compare this
exact moment to the manga it was
actually Nami who decided to tie up
bagi's limbs with some rope here however
the reward for saving this Village was
nothing compared to what it was in the
anime that's because the mayor of orange
Town offered live-action Luffy this tiny
basket of food but in the original the
crew came away with giant sex stuff full
of goodies which now brings me to maybe
one of the most controversial changes to
the live action which was all the times
that Nami hinted that she was never
going to betray the crew and what it
kind of did this weird oh is she gonna
stay is she gonna go oh she's actually
leaving thing during the baratia overall
I just feel like that really kind of
spoils the one mind-blowing Twist from
the original East blue story when Nami
abandoned the crew at baratier kind of
seeming actually evil and of course on
the other hand it was amazing to do
these kind of like mini earbud versions
of the transponder snails which no never
have shown up in the original story and
so now we come to the single most
changed Arc of the entire story and
that's of course syrup village where we
meet USA for the very first time and man
this place is
so so different like the live action
turned this tiny little peaceful Village
in the Hills into like this super busy
ship building islands and I have to be
honest at first I really hated this but
I finally eventually came around to like
it when the live action kind of added
Luffy describing his perfect chip which
just goes to show how important the ship
is as a part of the crew plus they
actually gave usop a brand new job
working on ships which kind of helps
explain a little bit better his ability
to actually fix up the marriage during
their future Adventures as we know them
from the anime but that's really just
the start of the wild changes in sir
Village because Nami bonding with Kaya
was never part of the original story
though I will admit that the added
character development for Kaya was
really awesome and she even gave my man
usob the very first kiss in the entire
story
Stones tell Sanji about that I guess but
then they dropped the ball on Kaya's
entire story arc by cutting the one
scene where she actually stands up to
Kudo in the original story I mean
seriously this was her one moment to
show some courage but nope gone and
speaking of Kuro they actually cut out
almost his entire crew which you know is
kind of important for a pirate captain
and if that wasn't bad enough they left
him with probably the most cringe
characters in the entire show sham and
Buchi plus they even cut out this dude
who was one of my favorite parts of this
entire Arc in the anime in the first
place then we also have to mention the
changes to this sheephead dude's story
because unlike in the anime Mary is not
a butler but instead he's Kaya's
financial advisor which is honestly a
little bit sad because he was one of
Kaya's only true friends in her entire
households and then of course he just
ends up actually dying dying unlike in
the manga where he survives and then he
was the one who gave the crew the ship
himself but now we sadly have some of
the worst changes in the live action for
me which unfortunately all involve Usopp
so first of all they took away usop's
long nose which maybe I can kind of
understand look wise why they did it and
then they made usup to literally nothing
during the final fight to save Kaya he's
supposed to be a coward who then
overcomes his fear not just a coward but
then the worst part is that he cannot
even fire a cannon like that's just
unacceptable to me he's supposed to be
an expert Sharpshooter who can hit a
rock super far away that is like his one
thing that he's actually good at and
they took even that away from him okay
but enough of usab let's talk about a
really dumb change for Zorro's backstory
instead and that's because in the
original story we see Zorro talking to
the master of the dojo before kuina even
ever dies however however in the live
action they literally never interact
until kuina's death which just makes
this awkward exchange where Zorro has to
ask for Queen a sword instead of koshiro
giving it to him on his own just feels
so weird they also make quina's hair
super blue for some weird reason instead
of its normal black and zaro's famous
sword is also slightly changed as the
blade is missing the normal black part
of the blade on the non-cutting side and
so instead of the texture it has in the
anime it just has this uniform shiny
metal kind of vibe to it but the one
change that I've been complaining about
more than anything else since the very
first promotional images of this show
came out is the way that the Mary's
figurehead looks here I mean isn't this
supposed to be the perfect friendly
little sheep not the stuff to summon
Satan and curse my nightmares
but another thing that made no sense
here too was how Luffy didn't even know
that he could blow himself to block The
Cannonball I mean he's had his devil
fruit for over 10 years since he was a
kid and in the anime he was doing way
crazier stuff than this with like no
problem at all and I know there was a
lot of negativity and the two episodes
in Sarah Village were probably my least
favorite so now let's move on to
probably the most amazing change in the
entire live action which is that they
really turned sanji's pervertedness
meter all the way down to zero like
maybe a little bit above but very low I
mean seriously it's like he's a new man
who just happens to enjoy flirting with
the ladies like Nami and nojiko instead
of being like super over the top weird
with girls like he is in the anime and
honestly really almost all the changes
at the baratier were just fantastic it
looks incredible and the best part was
that this place really gave us drunk
Usopp and what else could we possibly
ask for in case you didn't notice they
also changed the reason why Luffy was
forced to work for zeph because
originally Luffy launched a cannonball
which crashed into the floating
restaurant drawn so he was forced to
work to pay off the damage but in the
live action he just didn't have any
money at all to pay the bill which makes
sense and was kind of funny and in line
with Luffy's character but a little bit
less cool in my humble opinion plus the
decision to just completely eliminate
Don Creek from like ever showing up at
the baratier was a simply amazing choice
because while I don't love the fact that
Garb felt that he needed to call mihawk
for help the world's strongest swordsman
new introduction showed us just how bad
as he truly is without wasting a ton of
time by bringing Creek to the baratia
and can I just say I love that they
introduced the Fishman in this Arc
already starting from this Fishman
serving as the restaurant's front of
house to arlong showing up like a mob
boss for the entire East blue it really
all worked out well to expand the scope
of the entire one piece world and the
East blue in particular I think however
arlang's fight with Luffy in episode 6
shows off one of the worst mistakes in
in the entire show I think and that's
because when arlong sends Luffy flying
we can clearly see that he's actually
hurting Luffy with these blows however
in reality Luffy's rubber body should
make him immune to damage from regular
punches kicks and even bullets like we
saw early in episode 1 when alvida
smashed him with her club and shot him
really the only thing that should really
cause Luffy any damage at this point are
sharp objects like blades or teeth and
of course the obvious threat of drowning
and also let's be real the original
Luffy would never never get crushed by
arlong In This scene because he is way
stronger than the Fishman but I guess we
can say it's because this version of
Luffy is in the end weaker than the
original anime version also can we just
point out how much usop's slingshot
looks like a toy in this shot I honestly
never got that feeling when seeing it in
the anime but maybe that was what they
were going for now if you've watched
through the water 7 Arc in the anime
then you should find that this next new
C mean is absolutely hilarious and
that's because when Sanji is talking to
Luffy and usop on the going Mary he says
that a captain's decisions are what
separates him from the rest of the crew
and then Luffy literally looks right at
usop which is just a really fun Easter
egg for viewers who know what happens
later on in the story if you don't know
I'm not gonna say anything and earlier I
said that sir Village looked way
different but this next set is also way
different from its original because in
the anime kokoyashi Village is shown as
a Tropical Paradise which hides the Dark
Secrets but in the live action they just
transformed it into a super rural
Village full of Huts which I mean makes
sense since these people are being bled
dry but I still miss the appearance of
the anime I'll be honest arlong Park
also had a very serious makeover they
basically made it a club with some
random carnival games thrown in there
which is a lot different from the
original location and the live action
also made one other really confusing
Choice during this Arc here and that's
because originally the people in
kokoyashi Village knew about nami's
sacrifice to work for arlong from the
very beginning which made them never
hate her in the first place but in the
live action they don't know anything and
there's just a super rough Dynamic of
Nami literally forcing the villagers to
cough up more cash and so these people
who in the original story actually loved
her in secret just think that she's a
straight out traitor here plus then she
had to spell it out for nojikos or her
own sister wouldn't hit her with a
shovel that's then they also cut out
these two Bounty Hunter brothers and
this octopus Fishman which honestly I
think is understandable and a good
choice why they cut out the octopus
because honestly it would take a lot of
really really good CGI to make this
character work at all however he does
play a pretty important role in the
future so I wonder if they'll actually
bring him back at some point but now
let's actually discuss some awesome and
some also kind of bizarre changes about
the world's greatest swordsman because
in the anime mihawk actually never came
to bharati looking for Luffy he only
came to the floating restaurant chasing
after Don Creek but in this version he
weirdly follows actual orders from the
Marines which is kind of out of
character for him I'd say the
live-action mihawk also makes a direct
comment about Luffy's head which is just
such cool foreshadowing off his
connection to Shanks and he actually
goes on to compare Luffy to Raja which
is the same thing that zeph does later
on when talking to GARP so there are a
lot more obvious connections to Luffy
and Roger than we ever had in the anime
where it's just kind of hinted at very
carefully however one absolute terrible
change I think that they made to his
awesome character are his boots I mean
just look at those things here and I
have nothing against cowboy boots but
honestly it looks like he's ready to
ride a bull not fight legendary duels in
my opinion but speaking of character
designs overall they made so many
amazing improvements on other characters
outfits in particular the straw hats who
were many of the outfits that we
actually see in volume covers of the
manga instead of sticking with the same
clothes from most of the East blue
although I'll have to say some changes
were a little bit too far out there for
me like Sanji literally wearing bands
while stranded during his flashback and
there were also Ben Beckman and belmare
who both kind of looked much older than
they should have in the original story
but the single worst character design
changed to me just has to be are long
and that's because this dude is just too
small let's be real in the anime the
Fishman Towers over Luffy and the crew
which really adds a sense of
intimidation and fear I mean seriously
look at this guy in the anime he's
basically twice as tall as ginzo but in
the live action he's just slightly
taller which just doesn't have the same
effect it looks he has like a two big
hit for a too small body and another
very odd change was that they made Nami
bury her treasure right next to her
mother's grave I mean nojiko even
pointed out how kind of messed up that
is which even with her excuse I think is
still messed up because in the anime
beaumare's grave was by the ocean and
Nami kept her money buried in a
tangerine Grove but there is actually
one other major change to the live
action that I haven't mentioned at all
yet and that is everything involving
buggy the clown and if you want to hear
my full thoughts on his added
involvement in the story and my entire
thoughts on all 8 episodes together then
you can watch my full breakdown in
review of the live action right here
Shanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one